Virginia State Supreme Court is backing
up the governor's executive order
banning firearms at Monday's pro-gun
rally in Richmond police arrested three
more members of a violent white
supremacist group in Georgia on Friday
after making similar arrests in Maryland
and Delaware the arrests are fueling
concerns that the rally at the State
Capitol could turn violent
Jeff police is in Richmond this morning
Jeff good morning good morning I'm
standing in right across the street from
the Capitol building right over there it
really looks like a fortress this
morning a lot of temporary and brought
in amid heightened security concerns and
after this wave of arrests across the
country virginia state officials remain
concerned that white supremacist
organizations could try to infiltrate
that rally on monday to spark violence
police in georgia swarmed this property
making arrests in custody members of
white supremacist group the base luke
lane michael Helterbrand and jacob kate
early investigators say they were
planning violence including murder
according to court papers the FBI
infiltrated the group capturing
conversations that included lane
bragging this organization is going to
be involved in whacking people
investigators say the men sent local
members of the left-wing group and Tifa
as targets they were training on land in
Northwest Georgia and often took
photographs some images of the group
were released this week in a Maryland
courtroom when three other members of
the base faced a judge say tab is what
we would categorize them as racially
motivated violent extremists they're a
neo-nazi group that believed in white
ethnicity and power and have called for
a white ethnos state in the United
States the alleged sell arrested on
Thursday which included Canadian Patrick
Matthews set its sights on Monday's gun
rights rally at Virginia's Capitol in
Richmond on Friday workers and law
enforcement continued to add two
security measures already in place amid
increased concerns white supremacist
organizations are planning violence
orange siegel is with the
anti-defamation league which has been
tracking the threats for white
supremacist
and racists who believe that a race war
has to start now they're trying to
leverage this moment and so they are
recommending that people show up to
start a battle
investigators believe members of this
group the base like to operate in three
man's cells what makes it which makes it
easier for them to blend in late
yesterday there was another arrest
connected to the group of man and
Wisconsin accused of vandalizing a
synagogue also the president weighed in
on monday's rally he says that the
Second Amendment is under attack and he
blames the Democrats Michelle Jeff thank
you
you